If you look at Seattle,
they had the most radical member of the city council box about getting visas.
Now Jesus is the richest guy in the world, Susan obvious,
targeted they're socialists.
But if you want to drive Amazon out of
King County and Seattle, you want to look at them. You know,
this is what AOC did when she blocked them from going into her congressional
district and cost that part of New York city when he 5,000 jobs.
And I don't think this will not surprise me one morning. Uh,
visas announced that Amazon was moving everything out of Seattle and the cost of
the tax both directly from Amazon and indirectly from all the
workers who would then leave would be just staggering. I mean,
it would turn into, it would turn Seattle into Detroit.
So with all this in mind, what do you think the Republicans, if anything,
could be doing better as we're watching monuments,
being taken down and we're watching the mob just run across cities.
Um, you know,
I see the Republicans are sort of talking a tough game and Trump's talking a
tough game, but,
but are they not doing something that they actually should be doing because this
stuff isn't stopping?
Well, look, I think there are a couple of things they should be doing.
First of all, in the long run,
they should the Republican national committee to go into every major city and
create a jobs prosperity and safety
chapter,
and start to organize everybody in the city to win municipal elections and
state legislative elections who are secondary thing people killed.
And then they ought to plant a flag in every one of these cities and say,
we're going to reach out to everybody. Who's secondary to having no jobs,
no schools that work they have and having your relative shot.
And if that fits you, let's sit down and talk about, you know,
how you can be accounted. Not, not,
we're not going to ask you to vote for some traditional Republican,
but we're going to try to help you take back your city. Second, I think, um,
that the president has to look at the example that Bobby Kennedy
set in the early eighties and the early sixties
when young of volunteers were being killed in Mississippi during the civil
rights move.
And it was clear that the local sheriff who may have been doing the killing and
the state police were not going to defend these people.
And what they did is they said, look, these are American citizens.
And if you're not going to defend them, we are. And they sat in the FBI.
And I think in a number of these places that the young woman in Indianapolis,
the mother of a three-year-old,
who was apparently shot over the weekend for saying all lives matter.
Um, you know,
th there's a perfect example where she lost all of her civil rights cause she's
dead. Uh, I think they ought to say, you know,
we, we are now going to create strike forces that are going to be prepared to go
into the South of Chicago, prepared to go into New York, any place which has,
is clearly spinning out of control. If you,
if you won't protect your own citizens,
we will because they're American citizens.
And I think we have to be prepared to,
to be much more aggressive and much tougher, uh, about, uh,
taking this on. And then lastly, we ought to create much bigger, uh,
and more attractive opportunities zones, uh, with, uh, benefits.
So great. And with, with education opportunities. So great. Uh,
though we can actually begin to create jobs in the inner city,
everywhere in the country.
Are you worried with all that in mind that this,
this mix between COVID and riots and protests is going to do sort
of irreparable damage to small business across the board?
No matter what at this point,
because if you weren't taken out by COVID and now again, with the lockdowns,
if you somehow survived, I have a friend who called me yesterday. Who's a,
who's, she's a misuse. She usually goes to people's homes.
She can't go to people's homes anymore.
She got a little shop over the last couple of weeks,
just a little one-room place.
Now they closed her down and she's thinking of leaving California now.
And she's not even sure what she's going to do for a living anymore.
That the average person, you know,
the corporations can basically deal with these big blows,
but the average person just can't figure out a way to live if every month
something crazy is going to have.
Well, I mean, even big corporations, Brooks brothers, Suzanne, which is a,
you know, almost 200 year old company, uh, may,
may actually be 200 years old, uh, as filed for bankruptcy, right? Uh,
United airlines. I mean, even really big places can get in trouble,
but the point you make is important at a couple of levels.
I work very closely, uh, with Alfredo Ortiz and the job creators network. And,
um, they do terrific work helping small businesses,
and we have been much more proactive than the Europeans.
They're trying to help small businesses.
But I think one of the things you're going to see is people are going to
leave. California. People are gonna leave big cities. Uh, I mean,
I would not be at all surprised to see New York moves virtually everybody who
has any resources, uh, just because the taxes are too high,
the streets will be in to be unsafe again. Uh, you know, people,
people don't want to be in a place that's out of control.
If you look at Seattle,
they had the most radical member of the city council box about getting visas.
Now Jesus is the richest guy in the world, Susan obvious, targeted a socialist.
But if you want to drive Amazon out of
King County and Seattle, you want to look at them. You know,
this is what AOC did when she blocked them from going into her congressional
district and cost that part of New York city when he 5,000 jobs.
And I don't think this mean we're not surprised me one morning. Uh,
visas announced that Amazon was moving everything out of Seattle and the cost of
the tax both directly from Amazon and indirectly from all the
workers who would then leave would be just staggering. I mean,
it would turn them that would turn Seattle into Detroit.
All right. So let's, let's back up a little bit, cause I know we can,
we can sort of focus on this for, for the entire hour,
but I think your career's sorta, well, we can,
we can do several hours on this easily,
but I think your career in some of the things that you have done might help sort
of light away that we can get out of some of this stuff. So when,
when you were speaker of the house,
can you just talk a little bit about how Democrats and Republicans could or
could not work together and what you think has happened that has led us
to just, I mean, there's virtually none of it now, um, how you were able to,
to make some of those fights and,
and build some of those bridges or have some of those bridges burned?
Well, I would point out that in fact, when the crisis really hit the spring,
uh, the house and Senate did manage.
Now give Steve Minutian certainly the treasury, some real credit,
but the house and Senate actually worked together and produced trillions of
dollars in spending. I mean, that was, they did it pretty fast.
They did it pretty cleanly.
They also has been a steady stream of small bills that people can get together
and agree on Lamar Alexander.
The Senator from Tennessee is probably the best example that he's a genius at
figuring out what they can do rather than what, what they can't do. Um,
but the key to, uh, we did, uh,
was very explicit and people want to know about it.
I can read a very simple small book, uh,
by Tom Evans called the educational Ronald Reagan, uh,
Reagan had, uh, after his movie career and his TV career,
he ended up spending eight years working for general electric. And, uh,
it was really interesting story because he went around the country as a
spokesperson. He talked even about 375 speeches to factories.
So we have a lot of practice talking to blue collar workers, taking questions,
being a celebrity, um, which was great preparation for running for governor.
And in the process, Reagan was in a period where he wouldn't fly an airplane.
He did a really bouncy flight in, I think, late 45.
So he did not fly an airplane again until 1965.
And so he went everywhere by train.
And the guy he worked for was a very conservative, uh, intellectual,
the head of, uh, human relations and union relations at general electric.
And so this guy would give Reagan conservative economic books.
So here you have Reagan driving, you know,
riding across the country and a train reading, conservative economics,
preparing his speeches. Well,
Reagan came up with a model which he really got from this particular guy,
which Reagan summarized in everyday language
by saying my job to shine the light on the American people.
So they will turn up the heat on Congress. Well,
what that meant was you had to have a program like three-year tax cuts that was
popular enough that the American people would say to their congressmen.
I really want you to pass this.
Looking for more honest and thoughtful conversations about politics instead of
nonstop, yelling out our politics playlist.
And if you want to watch full interviews on a variety of topics,
watch our full episode playlists, all right, over here,
and to get notified of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and click the notification bell.